[Music]
welcome back so we've been talking about
the fast Fourier transform and how you
can use this to compute the Fourier
transform on vectors of data and you can
use this to denoise data analyze data
also to approximate the derivatives of
data numerically and today we're going
to talk about how to use the FFT to
solve the FFT to solve partial
differential equations FFT for PDEs
okay and we're going to do this
numerically and so what I'm going to
walk through here are a couple of
examples the heat equation the one-way
wave equation and burgers equation and
we're gonna see how we can code up and
simulate these partial differential
equations using the fast Fourier
transform to approximate the derivatives
okay so we're gonna start with the heat
equation and I just want to remind you
the heat equation is U T equals alpha
squared u xx this is the one-dimensional
heat equation where u is a temperature T
as time and X space so maybe I'll write
that out U is a function of X and T and
I'll just label these this is my
temperature X is space a spatial
variable and T is time and what we're
going to do is we're going to Fourier
transform this so we're gonna take the
FFT and we're gonna get some U hat of
now Kappa and time so this is still a
function of time but now Kappa is a
spatial a spatial frequency or a wave
number sometimes I call this Omega
sometimes I call it Kappa but I try to
remember to use Kappa when I'm doing the
Fourier transform with respect to X so
here before you transforming the X
variable space and instead we're
replacing X with these spatial wave
numbers Kappa okay and the key
observation here is that if I have
derivatives like u X or u X X then when
we Fourier transform these
what we get is this UX derivative
becomes the complex number I times Kappa
times u hat if I take another derivative
that's just I squared Kappa squared u
hat which is minus Kappa squared u hat
so it's easy to compute derivatives in
space in this case just by Fourier
transforming and multiplying by by Kappa
or Kappa squared okay now this is we've
already seen this before but when we do
this with the fast Fourier transform
now this u hat is a vector of Fourier
coefficients u would be a vector of data
in each spatial location and u hat is a
vector of Fourier coefficients and Kappa
and Kappa squared are vectors of
frequencies so now what we get is
something like minus Kappa one squared u
hat one the first component of U hat
Kappa 2 squared u 2 hat and so on and so
forth down to Kappa n squared u and hat
the nth component so this is again a
vector of the product of Kappa squared
times times u hat and once you take this
vector and inverse Fourier transform you
would recover in this case the second
derivative of U ok so that's what we're
gonna do we're going to use this kind of
formulation to approximate first and
second derivatives and we're going to
use that to solve this PDE in matlab
using using ode45 and we'll use OTE
int in in python okay so will some of it
in MATLAB and in Python and here I'm
just gonna Fourier transform the
equations and what we get is u hat this
is still a function of time so I can
still take its time derivative so u hat
derivative equals minus alpha squared
Kappa squared u hat okay and the thing
to remember here is that u hat is a
function of Kappa and time so for every
single Kappa there's a discrete set of n
Kappas for each of these Kappas
this is just an ordinary differential
equation in U hat at that particular
kappa okay this is just an ordinary
differential equation and u hat dot
equals some constant times u hat and we
know the solution of that it's you know
e to the lambda T where this is this is
lambda and so we can solve this this
this differential equation using OD a 45
or we could even do this analytically
and so that's going to be really useful
okay so this is essentially a decoupled
so that's also really nice is that for
every Kappa this is a single
one-dimensional OD e so I get n OD es so
I have n decoupled OD es one for each
each of these Kappas okay so for each of
these Kappa J's let's say I have one
ordinary differential equation I have to
solve okay good so what we're gonna do
is we're going to code this up and we're
going to to simulate this essentially
using just a regular or OD e solver
using the fast Fourier transform to
approximate the derivative and then
we're gonna try this out for the one-way
wave equation and also for burgers
equation okay so let's let's start that
out okay so you can download all of this
code at databook UW comm it's all there
it's also on github now and so what
we're gonna do is we're going to start
I'm just gonna walk you through this
code what we're gonna start by doing is
defining some domain over which we're
going to define this PDE so in this case
we're defining a domain with length 100
from minus 50 to 50 and I'm gonna have a
thousand points in that that domain so
that'll that'll set up a certain Delta X
okay so this is just setting up the
problem then what we're going to do is
I'm going to define this vector Kappa of
discrete wave numbers so there's going
to be a thousand of those Kappas and
this is this is just how I always
remember to do it in MATLAB this is kind
of a pain but you're gonna you're gonna
just either copy this out or Google it
or whatever
we have this basic this basic frequency
given our domain of length L the basic
frequency is 2 PI over L and then you
imagine that those wave numbers
you'd have 2 PI over L times 0 times 1
times 2 times 3 all the way up to N and
those would be all of your discrete
frequencies and so here we create this
vector from minus n halves to n halves
minus 1 you multiply all of that that
array of frequencies or of integers
times this basic frequency and then you
run that through this FFT shift command
in MATLAB which reorganizes those those
wave numbers to be in the right order so
that each you know Capital One is the
wave number corresponding to the first
entry of the Fourier transform Kappa 2
corresponds to the second entry and so
on and so forth so this just makes sure
that your Kappas have the right order so
that when you multiply them by your
Fourier transform it's an apples to
apples comparison ok and this is just
kind of I think kind of a remnant of the
fact that lots of computer languages set
up their their wave numbers differently
and so you know this is probably has
some old programming language used to
set them up and so if you copy your code
you have to run this fft shift Kappa
command ok not a big deal you'll
remember this next time you see it
ok so we've set up the domain we've
defined our discrete wave numbers here
we're going to define the initial
condition so in this case what we're
going to do is we're going to start with
a top hat function ok so our initial
temperature distribution is going to be
0 then it's going to go to 1 then it's
going to go back down to 0 and we know
how the Fourier transform of this is
gonna is going to evolve in time what's
gonna happen is immediately the high
frequency corners are going to diffuse
out and round out and then very rapidly
after this starts to round out after a
while it will start to diffuse more and
more and more into this kind of
diffusing Gaussian profile ok so that's
what we expect to happen from the
analytic Fourier transform solution and
we're gonna see if that happens when we
simulate this ok
so all of the magic in this coat
everything almost all of the code is
just initialization and plotting the
real guts of the code are here in line
18 this is where all of the the
simulation is happening using Oh de 45
okay so what we do is we're basically
solving this equation here in Oh de 45
okay so I have a vector state u hat u
hat is the state of my system at each
time and for each element of U hat for
each Kappa right it's it's a vector of
Kappas for each element of this U hat
vector this is my ordinary differential
equation for that for that that row or
that Kappa and these are all decoupled
differential equations so each one only
depends on its own kappa and so what I'm
gonna do is define this right-hand side
heat is going to be this right-hand side
of the heat equation and it's gonna have
four arguments it's gonna be a function
of time it's gonna be a function of the
state you had the thing we're
integrating the state of our Eau de and
also a function of Kappa and Alpha Kappa
and alpha here and in MATLAB OD 45 is
expecting a function a vector field
that's just a function of time and your
state T and U hat and so this at t comma
u hat what that does is that creates on
the fly a function with just those two
input variables by taking this function
with four variables and locking in that
specific Kappa and alpha that were
defined up above in the function okay so
that's a little bit convoluted but all
we're doing here is we're taking our
right hand side function that we defined
as a function of four variables we're
locking in Kappa and alpha that forces
it to be only a function of the two
variables that ode45 is expecting this
function to have and then you also give
it a vector of x t to integrate over and
an initial condition and remember what
we do is we take our initial condition U
naught in space and then we Fourier
transform that initial condition to get
an initial set of Fourier modes okay so
that's all that we're doing here I will
show you this right-hand side heat okay
so this is my
my right-hand side for the heat equation
in Fourier transform and what we do is
essentially just code up this right-hand
side here so u hat is a big vector of
Fourier coefficients Kappa is a big
vector of these frequencies kappa 1
kappa 2 and so on and my the time
derivative of u hat d u hat DT is minus
alpha squared times Kappa squared times
u hat that's you know minus alpha
squared times Kappa squared times u hat
and because Kappa is a vector and u hat
as a vector we're doing dot squared and
dot times u hat and that does this
element wise squaring in product ok so
all we've done here is we for u
transformed our PDE we now get a system
of n coupled ordinary differential
equations one for each Kappa in this
this vector of Kappas we build this
right hand side in the Fourier domain
and we pass this right-hand side to
ode45 and it steps this u hat forward in
time as if it was a big system of
ordinary differential equations and it's
nice because these are decoupled
ordinary differential equations this is
a diagonal system of ordinary
differential equations ok so that's
really nice ok so we're going to go back
to our code here and now I'm just going
to run this ok so it's running and in
lines 20 through 22 all that i'm doing
here is i'm taking my solution at each
snapshot in time and i'm inverse Fourier
transforming it so I can plot it for you
ok
so essentially what we're doing is we
are taking our PD you were taking our
initial condition U naught were FF
teeing it we're simulating this whole
system in the Fourier domain so we're
walking this forward using OD 45 in the
Fourier transform demand we're literally
integrating u hat forward in time and
then once we have our solution in time
we can inverse for you transform and
figure out what was our solution in
space for each point in time ok and now
I'm just going to show you how to plot
this I like this waterfall plot because
I think this looks pretty cool
so I'm going to show you how to plot
this in a waterfall okay so this is the
solution in space and in time starting
with this top hat function and it looks
very very similar to what you expect
okay so what we have here is you can
kind of rotate this thing around and
what you see is that this is very much
like what you would expect you start
with this the sharp edged top hat
function and very quickly these these
corners diffuse out so those are high
frequency corners corners have a lot of
high frequency content those diffuse out
and round out and then over time you get
this kind of smooth diffusion this kind
of convolution with a Gaussian kernel
that gives you this smooth diffusion of
the heat profile as time evolves okay so
that's exactly what we expect from the
analytic solution from the physics of
the problem here we're solving it purely
with OD e45 in the Fourier transform
domain so that's really cool and I just
want to remind you that you know each of
these u hats contains the frequency
component so the first u hat is the
lowest frequency the next lowest the
next list and then higher and higher and
higher all the way up to the highest
frequency component and so what you can
see here just from this Fourier
transform equation is that the larger
Kappa is the higher frequency components
will essentially die out faster okay so
this is kind of the eigenvalue and the
solution would be e to the lambda t this
is a bigger decay constant when Kappa is
larger so my higher frequency modes are
going to die out faster my low frequency
modes are gonna stick around for longer
and that's exactly what we see here is
that these corners have a lot of high
frequency content those die out very
very fast in time and then the low
frequency big broad structures stick
around for a long time because they have
a lower decay constant okay so you
clearly see that in the physics you also
see that in the simulation so this is
really nice where we're kind of very
efficiently and accurately simulating
these derivatives by working in the
Fourier domain where we can solve the
system as if it was a system of
decoupled oneis
okay and then the other plot I like to
show is just a movie so what I'm gonna
do is instead of plotting the waterfall
we're just gonna plot each frame of this
as a movie evolving in time so you can
see kind of the diffusion occurring in
time I'll run that one more time for you
okay so you start with your top hat and
then you see very rapidly the profile
decaying in time
okay so again you see that even within
the first frame this very high-frequency
corner gets rounded out and then it
takes a lot more time for the other
frequencies to start to decay out okay
good so in the next few videos I'll walk
you through a couple of other PDEs we'll
look at the one-way wave equation and
the burgers equation and we'll see how
we can solve those in the Fourier domain
using using this here okay thank you